Hello everyone. I am Dr. Rachel French.
I'm director of planning for the
district and the project manager for the
consolidations effort. This is going to
be a very brief overview of the draft
deliverable that you that we released on
October 3rd. Um please go to
austinisd.org/conolidate
and look through all of those materials.
This is really to prepare us for our
community meetings and make sure that um
you'll have access to the information in
a variety of ways so we can focus on
conversation next week when those begin.
All right. So, our vision, we want every
family to have access to an excellent
neighborhood school. And so, we do look
at where schools are located as well as
just where people live because we want
the school that you are zoned to to be
wonderful. And that is something that we
are really focused on in this effort.
And we'll also talk through a little bit
about the fact that choice will still be
there. We are not removing the ability
to transfer to other schools. But we
really need to do a better job making
sure that every school is vibrant, well
resourced, and able to make the needs
meet the needs of all our students.
This graphic just demonstrates all the
parts of this effort as well as
highlights that we're here because of a
budget shortfall as well as declining
enrollment. So we are then looking at
school closures, emerging schools,
program changes, boundary changes. Um,
if you want to hear more about our
baseline academic programming effort,
please refer to the October 9th board
meeting recording, there's a great deep
dive into our efforts there. I'm really
going to be focused on the closures and
boundary changes in this presentation.
Let's get to it. Um, we are not starting
from scratch. We are building on work
from the 2022 long range plan and bond
program as well as our equity
assessment. These all involved lots of
community engagement. Um, and we
referred to them throughout our process
to make sure we were continuing on with
the recommendations and goals that our
community had set forth.
If you've been uh involved in this so
far, you've seen this graphic. There
were two parts of our decision-making.
One was really just data. It wasn't
decisions at all, but just highlighting
what's misaligned in our buildings. Um
as and now really where it gets to the
proposal that we delivered came from the
contextual analysis. The rubric was just
school level mis misalignments. Where
are schools too full, too empty, um in
poor condition, just data points. We
need to look at all of these in context
to make actual decisions and propose
solutions. And so we had to look at what
was happening to a school and all the
schools surrounding it to understand
what the actual strategy is that would
help our system as a whole. We know that
this process is hard and will be
challenging and all of our
recommendations or proposal is for
looking at the system and the district
comprehensively. So I just I don't want
to shy away from that. This is real
impact and real change to students and
families. Um, and we will do our best to
partner and ease that transition as much
as possible, but are confident that we
are doing what is best for the district
as a whole.
At the start of this effort, we wanted
to get as close as we could to 85%
utilization. This basically means the
percentage of how many kids we can fit
in all our schools versus how many we're
actually fitting. So, we were at 76% as
a district. We got to 82. So, not quite
at our goal even with closing 13
schools. We want to close as few as
possible and we're comfortable not
hitting our target in this case. We did
hit it at the elementary level as you
see. High schools were already pretty
close and middle schools we had some
limitations in terms of what we were
able to do due to taps and restarts and
are comfortable with where we are at
this point in that percentage.
Uh it also is important to highlight
that the changes depend on what's
happening in different parts of town. So
again getting back to some areas do have
more seats than students whereas others
are already pretty aligned at the
regional level but perhaps a school
itself is too full or too empty and
therefore might need a boundary
adjustment to supplement that. We also
know boundaries will change who is
zoned, but we also have to make sure we
are tuned into our transfer policy and
our transfer practice and so that way
our actual enrollment also becomes more
aligned and that will be a bit of a
longer term effort that we can't fix
with just boundaries. So again
reiterating a lot of what you'll see
here is based on where students live and
where they are zoned, not necessarily
where they are choosing to go to school.
At the elementary level, we are
proposing to close these campuses on the
screen as well as shift the ones in blue
to from a neighborhood school to
supporting a non-zone program. So
instead of having a boundary, they will
be available for any AIS stu AISD
student to apply and participate in
those programs. And I'll talk about that
a little bit more.
And here you'll see where those students
are now assigned. So the school on the
left of each column is the school that
is closing. The blue the schools in blue
are now where those students will be
reszoned and the boundary drawn redrawn.
And the percentages are the percent of
students sent to each of those campuses.
We tried to keep communities together as
much as possible but are just not able
to in all circumstances.
Here you'll see that same shift, but
from our non-zone programs um and where
those students are now zoned. We do, and
I'll reiterate this throughout, we will
be working with these communities to
ensure that as many that want to stay at
their school can stay at their school.
And so I know that requires different
efforts depending on what it's shifting
to, but we are very much committed to
these being a merger and really making
sure that we um respect and acknowledge
the community and students and families
that have really made these schools what
they are.
Part a lot of this shift is related to
dual language. Um uh the way we operate
dual language as a diff district, we
ideally would have 50% emergent
bilingual or Spanish speakers and 50%
non-emergent bilingual or English
speakers. Um and we are not able to
reach this ratio in our current quote
unquote wall-to-wall schools. Um that's
where every classroom supports dual
language and it's really a product of
where these buildings are located and
where our emergent bilingual students
predominantly live in the city. And so
we are proposing new locations for these
programs based on where the emergent
bilingual students live as well as the
dual language enrollment in that part of
town. We want to make sure that we can
support both a robust schoolwide program
while also being able to support strong
dual language programs at the
surrounding neighborhood schools because
we want to give students that are
emerging bilingual a choice. Um, and so
we wanted to be confident in their
locations that we can support both.
And we also in this move added
approximately 590 total seats for
schoolwide dual language. There was high
demand for these programs and this way
we're able to support their growth but
in the location that best serves
emergent bilingual students. In the
chart, it shows the current
participation of emergent bilingual
students at the four existing
wall-to-wall campuses and the potential
participation if all of the dual
language students from both school
communities choose to attend the new
location. Again, this is just a
potential. We know that we will work
with the communities to help families
understand their options and make the
choice that's best for them.
We've also already started to get
community feedback on the proposal and
y'all have noticed that there are times
that we are able to meet our guiding
principles that you see on the screen
and times that we aren't and this is
often because they're in conflict with
another. Um there are some situations
that we're able to hit all of them and
there are others in which if we balance
enrollment it would create a misaligned
feeder or vice versa or we're trying to
minimize impacts on a group of students
but it could impact the long-term
stability of that strategy. And so we
have to think of all of these in concert
um and just tried to be as transparent
with our decisions and are happy to
answer questions about those specific
decisions in our community engagement
efforts.
Just to give y'all a glimpse of where we
landed. So on the left you'll see if you
were to stack every elementary, middle,
and high school boundary on top of one
another what it looks like. And you'll
see that there's lots of little splits
and that is a group of students being
separated from one from one group as
they move up through middle school and
high school. And what you see on the
right is a lot less splits. There are
still splits, but they are much
healthier and they are larger groups of
students that are traveling together
from elementary to middle to high
school.
And we're now going to talk about the
specific changes at elementary, then
middle, then high school. So again, I
already spoke about the dual language
move. And again highlighting the fact
that we want to really respect all eight
of these schools and what is beautiful
about each one of them and are very much
committed to making this transition a
success. Um Riley will be merging with
Wooten Ridgetop with Pickle Becker and
Sanchez and Sunset Valley and ODM. You
will also have choice. This is you know
we heard from the community that the
communities want to stay together which
is why we have structured it in this
way. However, there is opportunity.
There are again more seats available
district-wide. So, if one of these
campuses better aligns with where you
live, um you're more than welcome to
apply to have a seat at that campus
instead of the one you see on the screen
here.
Looking at North and Northwest Austin.
So, again, we'll go regionally. Um this
part of town has space for many more
students that actually live here, but we
are only closing one school because we
are converting two to these non-zone
programs. So again, that allows us to
balance the size and number of our
neighborhood schools with the number of
students that live here. Um, and we are
much better aligned there. And so we are
clo proposing to close Bington and
Wooten and Pickle will support a
schoolwide Spanish dual language
program.
Looking at North Central Austin and
again, no one get too stuck on the names
here. This was just to really cluster
regionally in terms of our decision-
making. But in this part of Austin, um
you'll see we are proposing to close
Berwoods and Ridgetop Elementary. Um
these are both small physical campuses.
The buildings are really small. Um and
that mean makes it difficult to operate.
They rely on portables and that is a
long-term strategy of our district to
minimize and there is space in
surrounding schools in the actual
buildings to support these students. And
so the Ridgetop students, they will have
access to schoolwide Spanish dual
language at Pickle and their
neighborhood students will move into
Riley. Riley also has Spanish dual
language wallto-wall. So that will be
available at Wooten. Um and then
Breerwood students are currently being
reassigned to Matthews. This is an
opportunity again we're already hearing
community feedback and there is space at
these surrounding schools to perhaps do
this differently. Our initial choice was
to keep as much of Cassiss together and
as much of Breer Woods together as
possible when making this shift. Um, but
that might not be the best solution. So
again, we will be working because we've
already heard from both communities some
opinions on where they're being
reassigned to. And we actually do have
some options here. So we can work with
Cassiss and Breerwoods and Matthews to
really make sure that what we're
proposing um in November really best
fits what the commun those remaining
campuses.
Looking at northeast Austin um we have a
you know three of these schools are
modernized and they're all really close
together at least the ones that are west
of 183. We are proposing to close when
monasuri and students will have access
to a monastery program but now located
at go valley elementary which we'll talk
through in another part of Austin here
you see. So in east Austin we have space
for almost double the amount of students
that live here. We are proposing that
Maplewood and Oak Springs both close and
merge with Campbell and Blackshere
respectively. There is room at Campbell
for all of Maplewood and there is room
at Blackshere for all of Oak Springs. So
we saw an opportunity to keep whole
communities together and that's really
important and will allow us to kind of
have a more clean merger and really we
hope productive conversations to bring
the best of both into their new
community. Um and then go valley I'll
talk a little bit more about this on the
next slide will be a monasuri and
Sanchez we're proposing to support that
schoolwide Spanish dual language. I want
to talk about how we got to this
decision. Um, as I said, this area as a
whole has twice as many space. But if
you drill down to Allison, Go Valley,
Ortega, Norman, Sims, Sanchez, and
Zavala, those schools alone have space
for 3,000 students, but only 1,700 live
there. We also, when you look at the
rubric, you'll see that Allison doesn't
have enough students in its zone. Norman
Sims doesn't have enough students in its
zone. Ortega doesn't have enough
students in its zone. And since they are
all together, it limits our options.
So Norman Sims, we are able to expand
its zone north into Panon Springs.
Allison, we were able to expand its zone
from Sanchez, south of the river. Ortega
is remaining and the best way to extend
its zone since it's on the edge of our
district there. Norman Sims was also too
empty. It's able to pull from Go Valley
Elementary's boundary. Where that leaves
us is this area in orange only has
enough students to fill one school. And
so instead of closing two more schools,
we propose the programming changes that
you see. So Sanchez operating as the
dual language program, really looking at
its proximity to the students from
Becker as well as it has the strongest
and highest percentage of dual language
enrollment of these three campuses. Um
so those students would be able to
remain at their school um and continue
on in that program at their current
campus. Um and then Go Valley was
selected as the monastery because of
within this orange area. Most of these
students live closest to Zavala. Um but
again this is one in which we can
continue to engage within you know these
three communities of what is the best
best solution and opportunities there.
But quite frankly, this was a decision
made so we just didn't have to close
more campuses. At the beginning of this,
our commitment was to really spread the
impact of this hard thing around the
whole city. And so, this is one example
of a strategy allowing us to do that.
When we look at Southeast Austin, we are
proposing to close both Wedane and Palm
Elementary. Again, able to fit the whole
Palm School community into Perez's
building. um and almost all of Wedane
into Rodriguez. There are some boundary
changes here because there were Perez
originally looped all over Langford and
Houston and just quite frankly did not
make geographic sense for those students
to access their school. So that was
something we were going to clean up
regardless which is why you see a bit of
some boundary changes in that part as
well.
Looking at South Central Austin, um
again we have almost twice as many space
for twice as many students than who live
here. Proposing to close Becker and
again their program of dual language
Spanish instruction will be available at
Sanchez and then um Dawson will close we
can fit all of Dawson into Galindo.
There is a, you know, Galindo's zone
originally extended south of 71 Ben
White and we were able to give those
students easier access to a closer
school and therefore Galindo was able to
really serve the dominant portion of
this area and then there were some
remaining boundary changes to balance.
Um, Becker will be reassigned to Zilker
in this proposal.
And then looking at South Austin, again,
Sunset Valley was one of those
wall-to-wall programs that will have
access to it to that program at ODM. So
ODM is becoming a Spanish dual language.
Um, schoolwide program, Sunset Valley is
proposed to close and Jocelyn will
transition to a non-zoned program
offering Spanish and Mandarin immersion.
Um, just to zoom in a little bit more on
what's happening in South Austin is
there's a lot of just shuffles and
boundaries, which is a little hard to
understand at first, especially um, when
you look at schools in isolation. Um,
but just in the ones highlighted, both
Boone and Clayton, Mills, Ker, Cowan,
and Casuric all had smaller boundaries
than the size of their building could
support. Kiker was closer aligned. Um,
but to make each of these actually have
a healthy boundary for the size of its
school, it therefore impacted all. So
that's why you'll see Kiker kind of had
a trade in boundaries and things had to
move down. Um, and so if there is
refinements to some of these boundaries,
that is absolutely what we are wanting
to talk about. But really just wanted to
highlight that the reason some of these
are so substantial is because of how
much disparity there was in schools in
South Austin in terms of their
boundaries compared to the size of their
buildings.
And then at the end of all of this, what
you see um here on the left is based on
where students live and are zoned how
full or empty a school is. So red means
very empty. Dark blue means too full.
And so you'll see on the right that
there is no more red. There is no more
dark blue. And all of our schools are
within kind of the healthy utilization
range that we set forth in our initial
guiding principles.
Moving through to middle schools, um we
are proposing to close Betach and Martin
Middle School. Um we are considering
keeping the buildings and would like you
know hope to collaborate with those
communities to reimagine their future
and programming um and explore
opportunities there. When you look and
we're going to then just talk about
north and south. So, we were a little
limited in the north um in terms of our
options due to the ongoing restart at
Web, Adobe or Bernett. Um but there
needed to be some shifts because not
even including the single gender middle
school, there's space for over 11,000
middle school students. Um but only
about 7,000 live here. Um we also needed
to create a boundary for Marshall. Um so
in this we are proposing to close
Martin. Um and this also really um
aligns with the feeder patterns and
changes at elementary, middle, and high
using the river as a natural natural
boundary. Um so a lot most of the Martin
students are being reassigned to either
Keeling or Marshall and those south of
the river reassigned to Lively Middle
School.
And then here is just a zoomed in view
of Marshall Middle School's new
boundary. Um, there were eight
elementaryaries that could opt in, but
they couldn't all fit in Marshall Middle
School. So, we had to look at kind of
where students live, how this aligns
with the new elementary boundaries as
well as the proposed high school
boundaries to minimize splits as much as
possible. And where we landed is about
half of the current Marshall students
that choose to attend live within its
boundary. Um, and again, those students
can stay there if they are currently
enrolled. Um and then looking south of
the river, we are proposing to close
betach. Both Covington, Lively, and
Menddees surrounding it were all too
empty from a boundary perspective. And
so this did allow them to become at a
healthier utilization. Um Mendes was too
full, but there were also some shifts um
as well. And Bailey also empty. So
you'll see these boundary changes meant
to really balance this part of Austin.
Um and then again just zooming in a
little bit more on the specific new
boundaries for Betachch. Um we were
allowed to better align school size with
neighborhood enrollment. And again we
would like to work with the community to
envision the future of Betachch's
building.
And similar to the elementary red is
showing our old old boundaries that were
too empty and on the right the new
Keeling is still too empty. Um and that
is intentional to allow for its magnet
program to maintain and there is also
still room at Lively. So both of their
magnet programs will not be affected at
this point in time. Um and so all but
one of our middle schools are in that
healthy utilization range. And then
finally to our high school areas. Um the
overall as you saw in that bar chart at
the beginning we were pretty close to
the number of seats we need versus our
available and our target. So there are
no closures of buildings, but due to
just shifts in the international high
school population, we are closing that
as an campus which was originally
operating out of Northeast Early College
High School sharing a building and
instead it will just operate as a
program at Navaro Early College High
School and there are no proposed
changes. Um the bigot to our magnet
programs or applicationbased programs.
the biggest shift we're making at the
high school level. Oh, again this just
highlights that international shift. Um
but we were really looking at um
making sure LBJ's boundary and Macllum's
boundary are just better aligned for the
size of their schools. And so you'll see
a utilization chart in a few slides, but
if every single student within LBJ's
boundary chose to attend, it would still
be less than half full. And then you had
Mallums, which would be 120% full. And
so there are some substantial shuffles
within boundary lines at the high school
level that we work to align with middle
school and high school boundaries to
make as clean of feeders as possible.
You will see that LBJ's boundary looks
disconnected as well as Austin High
School's boundary looks disconnected,
but that is really due to the shape of
our district um and really can operate
as a cohesive boundary and align with
changes. Um the LBJ boundary aligns with
changes at the middle school level.
This is looking at high schools in South
Austin. Again, Akens uh really looking
at balancing enrollment. So Travis and
Crockett were both too empty whereas
Akens was too full. And so move
reassigning students allows us to ensure
that all our high schools are at that
healthy utilization which is important
for our goal of making sure we have
excellent neighborhood schools for all
students.
So here is the comparison of our before
boundaries for high school and our
current boundaries you see on the right.
You can go on the website and put in
your address to actually see your new
assignments. Um so again
austinisd.org/conolidate
org/consolidate.
Um you can also find information on our
transition planning. So please read our
draft deliverable which has timelines
for what staffing um student support
campus culture um all of that to make
sure that we are supporting. We
definitely want feedback here and we'll
provide refined proposals in the
November deliverable.
I'm now just going to really highlight
the staffing guide that you can also
find a link to. Um, principles for all
of these c all campuses impacted by a
closure um will be happening in
December. Um, and then we'll start
making staffing allocations in January.
We
often hire six to 700 students a year.
Um, and so instead of hiring from with
from outside, we will be starting to
hire from within. And so starting with
staff from our consolidated schools um
and are confident that we'll be able to
maintain um and prioritize staff um in
such a way. So look at the staffing
guide for more details of our staffing
process. Um just to give you some highle
ideas of our transfer policies. If your
school is not going to close or change
programs and your student is enrolled
there, regardless of if they're uh zoned
there, an indistrict transfer, out of
district transfer, if you attend a
school, you can stay at that school as
long as it does not close and its
program did not move. And then um please
read there's more detailed bullets.
Another one we've gotten a lot of
questions about has been siblings. So
siblings will not be automatically
grandfathered unless they're currently
enrolled as well. um but they will still
be a part of our prioritization in terms
of transfers. So siblings are not
guaranteed but they are still
prioritized as they have been. And so as
a whole families have three choices. You
can enroll in your new zone school, stay
at your current school or move with your
program or apply for a new program or
general transfer. Again, that is still
an option for all students. Um I do want
to say that you do need to reregister.
No one will be automatically reenrolled,
but grandfathered transfers will be
automatically approved. Um, and we can
provide more clarity on that. Um,
for the sake of time, I'm going to go
quicker um through these, but please
read through them on our deliverable.
Um, transportation policies are not
changing. So, our same two or more mile
from your zone school will remain. There
are some shifts that are happening um in
terms of some special rules and
situations that we were providing
transportation for. So please look in
the deliverable for more information
about that. We are also not currently
proposing to provide transportation for
our school the new non-zone programs. Um
so that is also something to note um and
please give us your feedback on. Um
grandfathered students will not be
eligible for bus service. So that is
also important to know as you make
choices and where to attend school next
year if this is approved in November.
Again, looking at the transition
planning, I won't go into detail here,
but just know that we've already begun
these discussions and as soon as things
are approved, we will be able to begin
in earnest and work with bridge teams to
really talk through work with each
campus and make sure students are
supported um as much as possible. Um,
our next community engagement
opportunity, we hope to engage with you
there, is October 14th, 16th, 25th, and
then an in-person session on November
8th. November 8th is where we will get
to share with you the changes we have
made and revisions we've made to the
plan. So, please stay tuned and stay
with us and engage. Um, we are actively
looking at our comment card. We have
already gotten 1700, so 1,700 responses
in counting and we are reading everyone.
Um, and so what you see on the screen
are just some of the feedback we've
gotten to date. Um, this is the timeline
that you've seen throughout this
process. Again, we are talking about our
draft plan. We are engaging and the
board will vote on November 20th. If you
have any questions, comments, please see
all of these resources. The comment card
will be available until October 28th.
And just thank you all for your
engagement and for being with us through
this really hard thing that we're doing
together. Thank you.